this is a production of cornell
university
all right so um my name is amara dunn
and i organized this session with my
excellent colleagues elizabeth buck abby
seaman and zaria marion zuffle who are
also on this call and you'll be hearing
from them
at different points during today's
session
um
so we're basically going to cover three
things in the next hour and a half we're
going to talk about what ipm is we're
going to do an overview of ipm tools
and you're going to spend some time
thinking about ipm on your farm
and these last two pieces the overview
of ipm tools and the thinking about ipm
on your firm are going to be kind of
intermixed so it's not going to be a
linear presentation
as i said before please ask questions
anytime in the chat we want to make sure
that we get your questions answered and
that's probably more important than
covering the content that we've prepared
we will also be asking you to
participate today
and we already appreciate your
participation in the polling responses
but just be aware of that we're here to
help you participate we know that
sometimes that's a little bit harder on
zoom but we want to help with that
and the reason that we include
participation is we think that it helps
you get more out of these sessions
all right so we're going to go ahead and
start with our breakout rooms and asking
you to do some participation there's a
lot on this slide don't worry i'm going
to walk you through all of it
um
so in a moment i'll be asking everyone
to join a breakout room
and then in this breakout room we'll be
inviting you to take a look at that
chart that i shared the link for in the
chat
when folks were signing on and maybe
elizabeth or abby or mary can repost
that link in the
chat so this is a chart that basically
just has months of the year and a place
for you to jot down what are you doing
to grow tomatoes so just a way to think
about sort of a linear calendar based
fashion what all is involved in
producing tomatoes because we know
there's a lot
the link you won't actually be able to
type into that chart on google drive you
need to download it and edit it on your
computer if you let us know ahead of
time that you were coming to the
workshop then i um sent you that
information and email yesterday
and if not you can get it um you can
access that on the through the link in
the chat
um so in the breakout rooms we'll ask
everyone to kind of fill out that chart
for themselves
and because you're in a small group
you'll have the opportunity to ask each
other questions um including wait how do
i get that chart and how do i download
something from google drive maybe folks
can answer those questions too
and chat a little bit about
what you
do to um
produce tomatoes
everyone's going to fill out their own
charts you can be focused on what you're
doing
on your farm so the way that the
breakout room thing is going to work is
in a moment you'll see a little window
pop up that says join breakout room i'm
not quite sure whose name is going to be
here it might be kim's it might be mine
but it'll say you're invited to join a
breakout room all you have to do is
click the blue join button
i'll set a time limit on the breakout
room and it'll probably be
around 10-ish minutes um
when you get to the end of the breakout
room there'll be another window that'll
pop up and say you have one minute left
the breakout room is going to close in
60 seconds and it'll count down
at that point you can either click this
blue leave breakout room button or you
can just hang out automatically the room
will close when the timer gets to zero
and you'll come back to the main room
while you're in the breakout room there
is also going to be a blue leave room
button so if at any time you want to
come back to the main room you can do
that
with the caution that if you click on
this blue leave room button
it will give you the option to either
leave the whole meeting which you do not
want to do or leave just the breakout
room
if you accidentally do leave the meeting
go back and find the link that you used
to join the zoom call in the first place
and you can get back in that way
the 60 seconds has not yet expired and i
think here comes everyone
someone in the breakout room i joined
described this as an adventure this um
zoom environment and i think that's a
good way to put it and i appreciate all
of you for being good sports in our
adventure
um
so
hopefully you had at least that gave you
at least some opportunity to think about
what do i do to grow tomatoes um because
we're gonna spend the rest of today's
session chatting about then your ipm
toolbox for growing tomatoes and as we
go through the tools in the toolbox
you'll be invited to think about where
do those tools fit into the things that
you are already doing to produce
tomatoes
so
i always like to make sure that everyone
is on the same page in terms of
using the same definitions it's really
good if we're all talking about the same
thing
so just really briefly integrated pest
management or ipm is all about managing
pests effectively while minimizing risks
and those could be risks to human health
they could be risk to the environment or
they could be economic risks right that
your
losses to your bottom line either
because of pest damage or recognizing
that managing pests has a cost
so ipm is also a holistic approach to
pest management
and
this means that we're using a lot of
different tools when we're doing ipm
ipm also involves not just reacting when
you see a pest but there are some steps
that precede that so ipm starts by
preparing knowing what pests you should
expect and when to expect them and also
understanding the biology of the pests
that you are expecting
when you are prepared and you know what
pests you might be looking for you can
take some preventative steps how can you
exclude those pests from your field from
your greenhouse or high tunnel what
cultural practices will help and how can
you grow healthier plants
looking to know when and if you have
pests is a really important part of ipm
so scout early and know what level of
pests or damage from pests you can
tolerate
and we'll talk some more about scouting
in a little bit
step number four is making a plan so
knowing what your management options are
if you find pests and they're exceeding
your tolerance or your threshold making
sure you know how to use those
management options and what the risks
are and these management options run the
gambit from cultural practices up to
chemical pesticides
and there's different risks with all of
those practices environmental human
health and economic risks
step number five is choosing and using a
management option that will be low risk
and also effective and then it's really
important to step back and
assess how well
your
ipm plan worked right so that you can
make changes next time
really importantly um i find this
encouraging as someone who is also
trying to do ipm um not in a commercial
production field but certainly around my
home um and in my home garden ipm is a
journey and not a destination there's
always room to add some more ipm
and you are probably already doing some
ipm
um
and so that i think is encouragement
your priority doing some and there's
probably room for some more
so
some of you were able to chat in the
breakout rooms i know there were some
technical difficulties with the breakout
rooms
but
what i would like to do is take a minute
and ask folks to either put in the chat
um
probably put in the chat as the easiest
um and i'm actually gonna uh type a
little bit here so you can all see um
what are some things that you do to
produce tomatoes and
when do you do those things
um and actually i have changed the
settings you can unmute yourself if you
would like to unmute yourself and just
share that is okay too
hi this is uh tony emmy
and uh pretty much in january and
february you start ordering seed
and
ordering other inputs
those two months are pretty much what i
do then
planning for seed and uh
and uh other inputs
great thank you
yeah my name is bob
horseford i've worked up some of the
soil in my hoop houses and i've started
some of my tomato plants
i got i have all my seeds and i'm gonna
after the year
great i just gotta start putting down
plastic and
biodegradable plastic um
which is a godsend even though it's more
expensive
it's great stuff um
so that's me
great
what are folks planning to be doing in
april may and june what do you
anticipate you'll be doing
hi this is uh tony again pretty much in
april
um
you're producing transplants in the
greenhouse
finalizing uh
you know what production areas i'm going
to use on the farm
and then in may you're actually transfer
you know tillage and transplanting
putting putting plastic down
and uh
in june you might you know at times will
transplant a lake a late uh crop
and um at that time two will start
if not in may start your spray program
um to protect against disease and
insects
i also saw so we've already got order
seeds on here
start planting in may
anything we're missing
all right
oh we have someone who is grafting
excellent all right
um so let's look at the second half of
the year
um so july august september october
november december what's going on in
tomato production during these months
and i realized we've got folks who are
doing different kind of production hoop
houses not hoop houses some people are
grafting some people may not be crafting
um so it's okay we've got a mix here
oh
did my screen sharing stop
apparently it did yes
all right well now you can see my
screens my screen again thank you um
for letting me know about that
yeah so july through december what sort
of things are folks doing with tomatoes
then
see in the chat someone was planting in
greenhouses last week excellent
hoping for an early start this year
so for july we have
watering
applying calcium
and scouting for diseases
when do you all start harvesting
i'm sure this will be different
depending on where you're growing
i'm gonna assume there's some harvesting
that is going on in august
also some pruning and trellising
perhaps some watering happening in a lot
of these months depending
on what the weather is like
you can add pest management whether
you're spraying for weeds or diseases or
insects
there's probably some pest management
here also
does anyone want to share
something that they're doing at the end
of the season when harvest is done
anything going on there
since i'm growing plants in a hoop house
it's a passive system
it's important after the plants are
killed by frost
that you clean out all the residue
because if you don't do it you're
setting yourself up for foliar problems
the next season
absolutely
i 100 agree would that be october for
you or a little bit later
no it'd be october okay
i'm usually out by
october 10th october 15th okay it's cold
here
yeah sanitation is very important and we
will talk about that i'm going to give
folks one more opportunity if there's
something you're desperate to add to our
chart before we move on and thank you
for those who have been sharing in the
chat and
speaking up
ah choosing and planting cover crops
excellent
great ipm practice
and someone else who's mowing everything
down at the end of october and planting
rye
all right
well thank you again everyone for
participating i know this is not a
typical thing we do in meetings but i
think it's um a little bit more fun at
least it's more fun for me than uh just
me talking the whole time so that's why
we do this
all right so um
the idea of having you share and think
about what you're doing for tomato
production at different points in the
year again is so that we can make some
connections between these ibm tools for
tomatoes and things that you're already
doing so
as marian and abby and elizabeth and i
go through the next slides um we'll try
to make some connections to some things
that were shared and encourage you also
to be thinking about like oh yeah i'm
doing that like maybe that wasn't in my
chart but i'm doing that already or hmm
i'm not doing that but maybe that's
something that i can add so we're going
to go ahead and start off with elizabeth
who's going to talk to us a little bit
about crop rotation
okay hi everyone so um crop rotation is
one of the most fundamental and easiest
things that you can do for ipm
pretty much everyone is already rotating
the crops it's the best way to break
disease cycles
and as a general
rule you want to aim for three years
between plants in the same family so as
you can see these peppers and
eggplants in the same family they're
always staying three years apart as they
rotate around between the fields
a strong rotation can
definitely help break disease cycles it
helps you move around and change your
wheat pressure avoid certain types of
weeds
depending on how far you can rotate
sometimes can also help with your insect
pressure overall a strong rotation leads
to a much happier
easier growing environment in generally
speaking um yes so i'm up next chatting
a little bit about sanitation and this
came up in some of the things that folks
shared already especially about cleaning
up um abby and mary and elizabeth and i
were talking and we felt like sanitation
we could really summarize with just a
lot of s's so you want to get all of
your s's um surfaces so for example if
you're producing um seedlings in a
greenhouse you want all your surfaces
all your bench tops to be clean
um seedling trays places where you're
starting your tomato seedlings those
need to be clean or they need to be new
and anything else that's coming in
contact with your seedlings the seeds
themselves should be clean um and this
picture over here um i still am not able
to say the name of this tool but it is
apparently a tool that is used in
cooking that can hold a liquid at a
steady temperature which is great if you
want a hot water treat tomato seeds
right because you need them to be at a
particular temperature for a length of
time
and apparently
this tool can be really helpful with
that
snips so any tools that we're using for
pruning anything that's going to come in
contact with the tomatoes those should
be clean and then this picture here
sous-vide elizabeth is saying is that it
sous-vide
i'm gonna have to learn i know no french
at all this is unfortunate elizabeth
says yes thank you
um so this picture here is showing some
sanitization sanitizing of wooden tomato
steaks
using your tomato steaks for just one
year and then burning them if they're
wooden is also a great way to sanitize
them but if you do need to reuse your
tomato steaks it's really important that
you sanitize them in between seasons so
this means
scrubbing all of the organic material
all the soil plant debris off of them
and then soaking them in
like a bleach solution that is going to
kill any bacteria that could be
overwintering
abby's up next with pest resistant
varieties
uh good afternoon um
so when we're thinking about the
varieties that we're going to grow of
course the first consideration is going
to be
um
what the market what we can sell what
our market wants
but um
after taking that all into consideration
um it's it's important to think about
whether there is pest resistance in any
of the varieties that um you grow and
maybe you could favor those particular
varieties
um
and this in these pictures here are a
couple of
varieties one of which has late blight
resistance and one of which doesn't and
this is
plants from the same trial in the same
year so you can see the level of
light light resistance you can get with
some of these varieties and
um there are more light blight resistant
varieties coming along all the time so i
think that's something to
keep track of if you can
magma graph
combs the seed catalogs and
her colleagues
trials looking for
recording the disease resistance of
different varieties of all the different
crops and you can find that information
on the cornell vegetables website for
for each crop and that's just cornell
vegetables.cornell.edu and that
website
will be on our resource list
so integrated weed management weeds are
a huge cost on vegetable farms take a
lot to control them and i always like to
say you know it's not one single tactic
when it comes to controlling weeds it's
many little hammers
and that starts with knowing what weeds
you have in your field and managing the
weed seed bank the idea is that if you
can prevent seeds from going into the
ground you can start to get further
ahead year after year and
you get further ahead also by knowing
the life history of those weeds so if
you can identify the weeds
then you can learn what the weak points
are in that weed's
life cycle and attack that weak point
cultivation is great because weeds do
not become resistant to steel
you know we do have herbicide resistance
for several of our weeds including to
some some tolerances to some herbicides
that we can use in tomatoes but there's
yet to be a weed that will survive a
well-timed well-piece well-placed piece
of steel
perennials will regenerate but we can
manage that
it's good to know what your crops
weaknesses are too so we're talking
primarily about tomatoes here right so
tomatoes they're in the nightshade
family that means that any weeds in that
same family nightshade weeds are going
to be
less likely to die to the herbicides if
we have an herbicide that kills a
nightshade weed odds are it's going to
be too tough on the tomatoes to use it
we know that with tomatoes vining weeds
are going to be a big problem because
they will start climbing that plant
climbing stakes
the the other thing that is a weakness
with tomatoes is really tall vigorous
summer wheats things like lamb's
lambsquarters and pigweeds and velvet
leaf because they like the same exact
growing conditions so everything we're
doing to make our tomatoes happy also
make those weeds really happy
and if you're staking your tomatoes
which a lot of people do
sometimes the layout of the field and
the actual height of the stakes limits
your ability to gather and cultivate so
we get a lot of weeds on the
edge of the bed we get a lot of weeds
late in the season
i always like to think about weed
management and those many tiny hammers
plastic mulch is great but
where's the fertility going if you're
feeding under the mulch through say a
drip tape that's awesome you're denying
the weeds their food if you're
broadcasting a lot of fertilizer out
then you're really only feeding the
weeds in between the rows so restricting
down your fertility pattern can also be
a weed management tool this could be an
economic benefit in a year like this one
and the final question is where are your
weeds coming from is there a chance that
you're bringing them in say with straw
or hay mulch is a chance that you have
uh brought them from field to field just
are they blowing in on the breeze
because you have a wedi section in the
hedgerow or along a ditch
and i always like to put this picture
out there you know
god give the folks an albion a uh a pat
on the back for trying to be positive
but
weeds are not beautiful in your tomato
field
not at all
all right mar
so
the next thing along lines of fertility
is it's really good to optimize the ph
and fertility um it's all a question of
balance right so if you have too little
of any given nutrient the way we talk
about that conceptualize it is a barrel
and every stave in the barrel that's the
the planks in the barrel is a different
nutrient you fill this barrel up with
water
the lowest plank is where the water
starts pouring out and the water
represents your yield just like in this
picture so you can have all of your
nutrient levels just perfectly fine
where they need to be but your yield
will always be limited by the lowest
insufficient nutrient okay
the
idea with this is that if you have too
little of any given
essential nutrient the plants become
stressed the stress plant is more
diseased and insect susceptible and
certain nutrients particularly the
macronutrients you can get direct
interference with fruiting and with
fruit quality
now obviously this idea of too little
also applies to water stress right
it applies to ph too so if your ph is
too low
those nutrients may be in the soil but
the plant isn't able to pick them up
they aren't freely available in the
water in the soil
on the flip side if the ph of your soil
is too high
a different set nutrients gets tied up
and is no longer available in the water
in the soil this tends to be a common
problem with tomatoes grown inside
greenhouses okay inside high tunnels
where the ph raises too high and we
don't have accessibility of the
micronutrients those are more accessible
at a little bit lower ph ranges
so with too much ph to a little ph we
have the nutrients in the field but they
aren't available
when we're just lacking the presence of
the nutrients they should be available
but they do not exist there um we have
too low if we have too much of any given
nutrients really lots of times we're
only feeding the weeds the crops don't
take up luxurious amounts of nutrients
they don't gather more than they need a
lot of weeds do they hoard it and as
they hoard it they get bigger and bigger
and get more and more seeds it can
promote the presence of certain pests um
it also can interfere with fruiting and
fruiting quality and it's
environmentally irresponsible so that's
the too little too much there's also the
timing of it when plants get fed
they they are they have a teenage phase
right and just like teenagers they will
eat you out of house and home
in this rapid growth phase there's no
point trying to prepare
you know three turkey sandwiches for a
five-year-old they're not going to eat
it but if anyone has had a teenage boy
in their house
they certainly know that three turkey
sandwiches will disappear quite quickly
your plants hit that stage
right when they hit the rapid growth
stage that's when you want to feed them
most of their nutrients if you feed it
too early or too late you're causing
stress you're losing yield if it's
nitrogen we tend to leach that's why we
don't want to see a lot of nitrogen
applied early we want to hit that
teenage girth phase and particularly
with tomatoes the window of high need
for
potassium which is directly related to
fruiting and fruit quality is going to
be at first flowering through golf ball
size of the first fruit that's when you
need to switch
and focus on potassium
and the last thing is that you always
want to feed a balanced diet you know
this is an actual picture of my
oversized house cat
and uh
he's too tubby he uh we don't want our
plants to be like that we have
macronutrients
micronutrients we want to provide
sufficient amounts of both but it's a
relationship about like this you know
you this made by the micros you need way
up here for the macros
um you want to avoid deficiencies at the
same time you want to avoid toxicities a
lot of the deficiencies and toxicities
you're going to control by keeping your
ph
just right
all right optimizing the environment is
what is being depicted on this slide um
and i'll be honest these are some pretty
nice looking on the steak tomatoes um
but and i realize that there are some um
growing situations where leaving your
tomatoes on steak that's what you do but
the reason that we steak tomatoes a big
reason that we steak tomatoes is to get
that foliage up off the ground not only
does that reduce contact between the
soil and the fruit
and if you've got some diseases in the
soil that can be a problem but it
improves air flow so you're going to get
a lot of better air flow around these
plants that are staked up off the ground
than you will when the plants are
leaning over and there's a lot of
humidity here in this foliage
um so obviously there's a lot of things
about the environment we can't control
right we can't control the weather but
thinking about what things you can
optimize and if you're growing in a high
tunnel
thinking about how you're letting air
move through what pruning decisions
you're making
that are going to improve air flow gets
more air flowing around your plants and
make an environment that is better for
your plants
marion you're up with pest id
yes thank you um so i'm going to cover
the next three topics which include the
correct pest identification
scouting and thresholds
so for an ipm program to be successful
you're going to have to know what pests
you are managing for and that is where
this pest identification is critical
so here i'm showing you four different
images of tomatoes
the damage seen on each one is different
two are bacterial we have bacterial
canker and bacterial spec
one is caused by a mite the two spotted
spider mite and then the last one isn't
caused by a pest at all but was um due
to uh herbicide drift so depending on
what the cause is or uh what the pest is
that's going to determine what
management you're going to use to
control it and if you even can control
it
so if you mistakenly think that the
herbicide damage was due to a disease
then your management of say using a
fungicide obviously would not be
successful
not everything that you're going to
find out there is a pest some insects
are beneficial and then there's also
some symptoms that you're going to
encounter that are due to
abiotic causes such as nutrient
deficiency or herbicide damage as seen
in the picture or
drought stress
but when you do have a correct
identification
then you can determine if first of all
if it is a pest um what other crops or
weeds might serve as a host to this pest
what life stage you want to try to
control
um whether the pest can overwinter if
there's any resistant varieties
available
and then also if the pest has a
threshold and then all the management
options that are available to you
so if you can go to the next slide
so i'm now going to cover scouting and
thresholds so to know what's going on in
your field and whether there are any
pests out there that you need to be
concerned with you obviously have to go
out there and look and you want to do
this regularly and this is called
scouting so ideally to scout your fields
you want to go out there weekly so you
can detect any
potential pests before they become a
problem
and by scouting weekly you're also going
to be able to see any changes that are
occurring over the season and then
you'll learn when certain pests occur
throughout the season and you'll learn
that if you're out there weekly and
observing what's going on
so to scout um you're gonna want to look
at all representative parts of the field
including areas that may be a little bit
different from the rest of the field
such as a wet spot or high or low spots
in the field areas near the edge or
along the tree line as you can see in
the back of the picture
you also want to um when you're scouting
start at different parts of the field
you don't always want to enter the field
at the same spot so you really want to
scout the whole field throughout the
season so
one week you enter in the northern part
and the next week you enter from the
south
and also when you're scouting you kind
of do it
to hit all parts of the field you want
to kind of do it in a v or a w shaped
pattern don't just walk down one row and
i know in tomatoes this can be tricky if
they're steak but you really want to hit
multiple rows throughout the field
and when you're looking at the plants
you're looking at the flowers the fruit
the top and bottom surfaces of the
leaves both the upper leaves of the
plant as well as the lower leaves and
then along the stems
and we usually recommend when you're
scouting that you're you should stop at
least 10 times throughout the field and
look at several plants at that stop uh
record the numbers of anything you're
finding your pests as well as the
beneficials
it's important to kind of keep track of
the numbers are they going up are they
going down if there are beneficial pres
beneficials present um are they
controlling your pests do you need to do
something else
so by scouting regularly you're
gonna know if a threshold has been met
but also you can assess if your control
measures were effective if you used any
control if you go out and scout have the
numbers going back down or are they at
least stabilizing
so the threshold that i just mentioned
is the number or level of a given pest
beyond which treatment is recommended
and the threshold can vary uh both by
stage by the stage of the crop but also
by what the pest is obviously it can
also vary from year to year and then it
also depends on your own bottom line
what what you can tolerate
so using thresholds
before applying a pesticide
can help you avoid these unnecessary
sprays and that obviously will save you
time and money
thresholds can be found in the vegetable
guidelines and at the vegetable
practices site of the new york state ipm
website and i'm going to post a link to
that you just have to copy it i'll post
the link to those so you can find your
thresholds
um and then we're going to move on to
abby about pest tracking and forecasting
yeah pest tracking and forecasting is
can be thought of in some ways as
another um
scouting or monitoring tool kind of
under the bigger monitoring umbrella
um and and and they can it can be
important for having early
warning about certain diseases
so that you know that they're in the
area before
before they actually arrive in your
field
and a good example of that in tomatoes
is late blight which is a
very dev can be a very devastating
disease that you really want to be ready
for
um before before it arrives in your
field you really
would prefer to not let it get there at
all
so there is um a national website that
tracks the occurrence of late blight
it's called usablite.org
and
you can sign up for text or email alerts
from this website
so that um and you can define the area
around your farm where you want to know
that late blight has been found
so just um this this website this um
relies on people reporting where late
blight has been found so it can be a
two-way street you want to get the
information from other people and you
also want to report for example if you
are the first person in your county
to find late blight and if you're in an
area with a vegetable extension regional
vegetable extension program
though the members of that the staff of
that program can help you with that
there are are some tomato disease
forecasts at the net also on the network
for weather and environment for
environment and weather applications
also called more easily nua
um
and that um at nua
uh is a
consists of a system of uh a network of
weather monitors that are on farms
mostly owned by farmers
that take in weather data from those
farms usually temperature relative
humidity and leaf wetness
and that information
like the how long it's been the leaves
have been wet and what the temperature
was when the leaves were wet can be used
to calculate disease forecast models
that can help time
um
fungicide applications
or and and there's also some insects
that are tracked
on the nuo website but
for cabbage and onions not for tomatoes
marion
manages a sweet corn pheromone trap
network that
monitors for tomato for corn earworm
which is also
aka tomato fruit worm
and so that can be another source of
kind of an early warning system a corn
earworm
can be a pest of tomatoes
and
it's very difficult to scout for
so the pheromone trap information can
give you an early warning of
when
the tomato the
corn earworm slash tomato fruit worm
moths are uh the numbers are high it's
usually when the on yours when the
numbers are very high and it's often
late in the season when we start seeing
them as a pest on something like
tomatoes or peppers
all right this is me um so biological
control using living organisms or
natural enemies to manage pests
is an important ipm tool and there are
different ways that we use biological
control so um this middle one um is
showing releasing natural enemies of
pests and this might be the one that you
think of first so what you're seeing on
this tomato plant here
is little bits of probably sawdust or
something else light that were sprinkled
on the plant what you can't see that are
hiding in amongst that carrier
is this predatory mite
and this is a predatory mite that is
hopefully going to be eating two-spotted
spider mite and controlling that pest on
tomatoes so this is something we think
about a lot when we think about bio
control oh you're releasing good bugs to
control pest bugs but there are other
aspects of bio control as well
so you might be conserving beneficial
insects that are already around your
farm
and so in this picture here this looks
like a bee but it's not it's actually a
surfeit fly and while the adults will
feed on pollen and nectar and they're
pollinators the larvae which don't look
very impressive are incredible aphid
predators and so having surfeit flies
around your farm um
can help can you control aphid
populations
this cute little insect down here is a
pink spotted lady beetle happens to be
hanging out on the cinea but both adults
and larval lady beetle immature lady
beetles
are great predators to have on your farm
and when you think about how you are
conserving them around your tomato
plants um this can take a couple of um
this can include a couple of different
things so
one aspect of conserving them might just
be thinking about what you're spraying
and recognizing that
when you are choosing an insecticide
that insecticide um could be not only
killing pests but it could be killing
beneficial insects as well and i i'm
sure you all think about that a lot in
terms of bees and how to protect bees
but there are also other beneficial
insects in amongst your tomatoes that
you want to be conserving as well
if you want to take it to a next level
of conserving
natural enemies of pests you could think
about what makes your field a place
where natural enemies want to hang out
and that could be a whole other talk of
how you
deliberately plant things that are going
to feed and attract and keep natural
enemies close to your tomato plants
where they can be helping you out with
pest control
and then over here in this picture we've
got a picture of somebody spraying um
because increasingly there are
bio-pesticides that are available to
control pests whether they're insect
pests or plant disease pests
these bio-pesticides some of them are
microorganisms
some of them are extraction plants and
some of them are naturally occurring
chemicals and so this is another piece
of bio control so this is kind of a
we put it as one tool in the toolbox but
there's really a lot of different
aspects to bio control that could be
part of your
integrated approach to managing
pests in tomatoes
okay back to me
so when we get to the point if we've
scouted our fields and reached a
threshold or have a reason from a
disease forecast to
start spraying often we have
some choices
of pesticides
and we can think about um
how we can how how we can think about um
choosing among them to minimize the risk
um both to our applica the people who
are applying the pesticides as well
as the impacts on pollinators and
beneficial insects that the amara just
talked about
so of course we we want to choose the
most effective pesticide that we can
always
but um
you know when we have a choice um within
the within of several or more effective
pesticides we want to take into
consideration um all of these different
factors including
is it something that's going to have the
potential to move into groundwater
that's always
that's always a bad sign
is it something that's going to have the
ability to
impact wildlife around your fields
so there are a few tools for comparing
pesticide impacts
one is called the environmental impact
quotient
and that is something that was developed
many years ago within the new york state
ipm program
and there is a invite there is a
calculator
for environmental impact quotient
for different pesticides on the new york
state ipm website
and the oh yeah the uh the eiq values
are also for it for a given um product
or also included in the cornell
guidelines for
commercial vegetable um
production another tool for comparing
pesticide products especially that's
especially useful for herbicides is
called a win pst
and that's available through the nrcs so
if you're
signed up for any um national resource
conservation service um programs
that might be a pesticide screening tool
that you're working with nrcs to use to
help you
choose
pesticides especially herbicides with
the least
environmental impact
the impa ipm institute of north america
has
a pesticide risk tool
that right now is available through a
subscription and it's
similar to the environmental impact
potion
in that it takes
pesticide impacts on different
potential targets uh human human targets
human uh
impacts uh
um
beneficial impacts uh risk of
leeching into the groundwater um all
those usual things that we're thinking
about when we're trying to minimize the
impact of our pesticides
and
there is some
amara has resources linked from her bio
control bites
blog
which has some information about
different pesticide compatibility with
um natural enemies or beneficial insects
that can be especially useful
in a greenhouse situation but it can
also um there's also useful information
for thinking about your pesticide
choices in the field because
whether you're releasing beneficials in
the field or you're just trying to
conserve the ones that are there
naturally
your pesticide choices especially
insecticide choices can be important
oh me again okay
um you have so much great information oh
yeah
i'm talking about pesticides today am i
um
so
one more thing again when we're thinking
about pesticides um
it you know especially for herbicides
these days
there are just so
so fewer so many fewer pesticides coming
down the pipeline i feel like it's
really important to preserve the
effectiveness of the pesticides that we
have
and so we want to think about the way we
use pesticides to manage pest resistance
to them
so one way to think about this is to re
avoid repeated use of pesticides with
the same mode of action
um that's that applies for
insecticides
fungicides and herbicides
and you can
learn what mode of action
a pesticide has from the pesticide label
there will be information
on the label as to what group
a pesticide is in so you can see this um
part this is from a fungicide label this
particular one is group 13.
and so you would want to not um
repeatedly apply pesticides from that
same group
in the same field in the same year
for insecticides this can be especially
important for especially small insects
that have a very
they have a lot of generations per year
you want to you want to not
apply insecticides with the same mode of
action repeatedly to a pest population
especially those ones that have multiple
generations per year because
you're selecting for the ones that have
a little bit of resistance and then
those are the ones that reproduce and
then you end up with a population of
increasingly resistant insects in your
field
using thresholds or forecasts to
minimize your applications is another
tool for managing pesticide resistance
the less pressure
in terms of number of applications that
you put on your your population of
of weeds insects or diseases um
uh will minimize the the
what they call selection pressure for
the resistant um populations
um if when if you can use a
non-pesticide option that's another way
again to just reduce the number
of
pesticide applications that that you
that you apply
and then uh again reducing the pressure
pressure the pest the
selection pressure on your pest
populations
phew okay go ahead amara
so i have yet another question for you i
warned you up front you were going to be
asked to participate um
so we've talked about all these tools
and you it would be very understandable
if you're thinking you know what i know
i should use all these tools but
it's hard it takes a lot of time um
i don't have the equipment
it costs money um
so uh this is kind of your opportunity
to do a little bit of maybe some venting
um so what what are the things that keep
you from doing ipm what makes ipm hard
you can go ahead and share your your
responses in the chat
and i'll add that we we really really
truly do want to know
what is difficult because we can talk
all day about how to do it but if we
don't know what's difficult then we
aren't really helping you that much are
we
a question are there resources um
i am going to put the link for our
resources in the chat
um and so we have on here all the links
i believe that were mentioned today um
and as i was listening to folks talk i
think i added a few um so that's the
advantage of this being a google
document is that we can add resources
but you don't actually have the ability
to change anything on the document so
don't worry you won't accidentally
delete something but you should be able
to access the links
um i did see that someone
sent a
direct chat message that um it's
they're not able to scout properly um
i can imagine a few things that would
make it difficult to scout properly um i
know it takes time to scout i know
maybe there aren't personnel who are
available to do the scouting so that can
definitely be a challenge for sure and
scouting does take time
you know
i've had amara so
i'm out and frequently making farm
visits and and that's a really common
thing that i hear is it's just hard to
get out and do proper scouting
and i i always when i talk with growers
and hear that as a barrier i always say
well
yes there is the full blown version of
scouting where you you go to ten spots
you look at five plants and you examine
everything closely
but a little bit of scouting is better
than no scouting at all
so if that just means that you walk the
field once a week and
that's a place to start then that's
great
you're starting on that ipm path and
you've found a way to do some scouting
and and it fits with your restrictions
and needs and time on the farm
i also remember a grower who
participated in this
part of our school last year who just
talked about
making sure that her farm crew
was able to recognize pests and and kind
of knew
at least to alert her when they find
when they find something unusual when
they're doing other things
you know so that's just another way you
know whenever you're out in the field
doing something or whoever else is out
in the field doing something
uh again it's like a good first step to
say hey there's something out here i
don't i'm not sure what it is maybe
maybe we need to think about um
finding out what it is and
you know understanding if it's a problem
or not or just just alerting the fire
manager to that
that's a great point abby
i something so i see someone shared in
the chat if you're working full time
away from the farm timing can be a big
issue especially trying to get your
available time to line up with the
weather and that is
100 a big challenge
um there's another direct message in the
chat it was a comment when you scout for
fungus if you see it you're probably too
late
happy elizabeth marion does anyone have
any
advice or suggestions about that because
that is a challenge
um
i i think i would say um that can be def
that can definitely be true for some
fungal diseases
um
but different diseases have different um
epidemic called epidemiology or just
different speeds at which they develop
and i'll for tomatoes i'll compare for
example early blight
which is a very common disease that i
think people
generally see
most years
i'll compare that with wipe light so the
early blight
i would say if you are doing a decent
job of scouting and can
catch it when you're seeing the first
symptoms
you're you'll probably do okay um
starting fungicides then
however late blight i would want to know
i would want to
not find late blight
um
and and and then have that be my first
response to putting on fungicides i
would always want to have fungicides
there so it does depend on the crop and
it depends on the on the mix of diseases
but yeah i think that's definitely true
for some for some diseases and not just
fungi
and i'll add to that i think
when it comes to disease management so
much can be done now with your variety
selection
and everyone's got their favorite
varieties right so
you may have a variety that you
absolutely love that doesn't have late
blade tolerance
i think it's a really good ipm practice
to put a small portion of your field
into something with light tolerance
especially if you're a grower who
has uh you know you work off farm and
you have time constraints getting there
and getting the scouting done
or you're someone who doesn't want to be
doing a lot of spraying and and you only
want to
um do as little as possible
and so
for diseases especially i feel like
there are a lot of really good
preventative or proactive
management technique so variety
resistance is one
using some sort of mulch or barrier and
staking your plants is huge for slowing
down
the pace
of
a early blight or septoria infection it
can help cut back a bacterial infection
because all of those diseases are
splashing up from the soil so by putting
a mulch down under the plants and
getting the leaves up in the air where
they stay dry you can really slow the
pace down
in terms of is it too late
i think with late blight that's really
the only one where it's too late with
the rest of the diseases if you're
watching the lower part of the canopy
those lower leaves you can catch it
early and a lot of it comes down to
weather if it's going to be hot and dry
absolutely you can get control that
situation if it's going to be
humid rainy
you're going to want to act pretty quick
and someone had asked for links again to
the information about tracking pests and
so i have a link for usa blight.org and
newa the network for environment and
weather applications and also the sweet
corn pheromone trap network reports that
marian puts out
and i think especially for late late
because that's come up a few times um
and the
part of the idea for this usa light site
is to know when light blight is getting
close so that you can take some
preventative steps
um
difficult to source alternative
pesticides
that is
a real challenge also
um
another comment that was shared with me
in the chat is actually a good segue to
the next thing that i need to cover um
someone shared you know so many of the
diseases and bugs just look alike how do
you tell them apart
and fortunately for you we have two more
tomato sessions tomorrow that will
address those very issues so
tomorrow um sign on at 11 45 content
starts at noon we'll be talking about
annoying arthropods so that's going to
be insects and then things that have
more than six legs and wedi competitors
um so we're talking about ipm
specifically focused on insects and
weeds
and then in the afternoon starting at 1
45 we'll be talking about diseases and
nutritional deficiencies and we have
some great experts who'll be joining us
to chat about those things
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu